aquí tengo dos definiciones distintas de
la función de dt si decimos que d es la
distancia y t es el tiempo entonces de
dtm nos da la distancia como función del
tiempo la primera es de de t igual a
tres temas uno aquí puedes ver cómo
cambian las distancias como función del
tiempo observa es una recta y bueno esto
es un repaso del álgebra podemos
referirnos a la tasa de cambio de una
recta como la pendiente de la recta y
podemos verlo aquí por cada cambio en el
tiempo podemos ver que tenemos un cambio
en la distancia en este caso cuando
vamos dt igual a 1 hasta igualados
nuestro cambio en el tiempo delta de t
es uno y cuál es nuestro cambio la
distancia bueno la distancia es cuatro
metros entre igual a uno y la distancia
es siete metros entre igualados entonces
el cambio en la distancia es
si queremos poner las unidades son 3
metros por cada segundo transcurrido por
lo que nuestra pendiente será nuestro
cambium en el eje vertical entre el
cambio en el eje horizontal que será
delta de d entre delta de t que son 3
metros entre un segundo o dicho otra
manera 3 metros por segundo y bueno
estoy seguro que puedes reconocer esto
como una taza si piensas en el cambio en
la distancia entre el cambio en el
tiempo esta tasa de aquí serán tu
rapidez todo esto es un repaso de lo que
hemos visto antes y lo que es
interesante de una recta o de una
función lineal es que tu tasa no cambia
en ningún punto la pendiente de esta
recta para cualesquiera dos puntos
siempre será 3 ahora lo que es
interesante de esta otra función de la
derecha es que esto no se cumple la tasa
de cambio siempre está cambiando y todo
esto lo veremos con más detalle cuando
trabajemos con cálculo diferencial
en este vídeo lo podemos ver como un
primer fundamento para el cálculo que
aprenderás en un futuro lo que es
importante considerar aquí es la tasa de
cambio instantánea en algunos puntos
pensemos en la tasa de cambio en este
punto de aquí si pensamos en la
pendiente de la recta que apenas toca la
curva en ese punto algo así es decir la
pendiente de la recta tangente y luego
pensamos en este otro punto puedes ver
que la recta está más empinada y por acá
parece que aún es más empinada por lo
que puedes ver que la tasa de cambio
instantánea crece mientras el tiempo
crece como mencioné en un futuro vamos a
crear las herramientas para pensar en la
tasa de cambio instantánea pero en este
vídeo podemos empezar a pensar en la
tasa de cambio promedio déjame
escribirlo la tasa de cambio promedio
y la forma en la que pensaremos en la
tasa de cambio promedio será utilizar
las mismas herramientas que utilizamos
en el álgebra es decir podemos pensar en
la pendiente de las rectas secantes y
que es una recta secante bueno hemos
hablado de ellas en geometría una
secante es una recta que intersecta a
una curva en dos puntos así que pensemos
en la recta que intersecta entre igual a
cero y entre igual a 1 déjame dibujar
esta recta en color naranja esta de aquí
así que esta recta es una recta secante
ahora podemos ver a la pendiente de esta
recta secante como la tasa de cambio
promedio desde igual a cero hasta t
igual a uno entonces cuál sería esta
tasa de cambio promedio
bueno la pendiente en nuestra recta
secante será el cambio en la distancia
entre el cambio en el tiempo
esto será igual a bueno nuestro cambio
en el tiempo es de un segundo y cuál es
nuestro cambio en la distancia
bueno pues entre igual a cero tenemos
desde cero lo cual es 1 y desde 1 es 2
por lo tanto nuestra distancia
incremento en 1 metro entonces tenemos
un metro en un segundo o podemos decir
que la tasa de cambio promedio desde t
igual a 0 hasta te igual a 1 es de 1
metro por segundo
bueno ahora pensemos en cuál es la tasa
de cambio promedio si vamos desde t
igualados a t igual a 3 vamos a dibujar
esta recta secante y vamos a buscar su
pendiente por lo tanto su pendiente que
también podemos ver como la tasa de
cambio promedio desde t igualados hasta
t igual a 3 ya lo hemos mencionado antes
la tasa de cambio está constantemente
cambiando pero podemos pensar en la tasa
de cambio promedio y ésta será
el cambio en la distancia entre nuestro
cambio en el tiempo
esto será igual a cuando te es igual a 2
nuestra distancia es de 5 así que déjame
ponerlo 1 2 3 4 5 aquí tenemos al 5 y
cuando te es igual a 3 nuestra distancia
es 10 6 7 8 9 10 aquí tenemos al 10 por
lo tanto nuestro cambio en el tiempo que
es bastante sencillo será de un segundo
y el cambio y la distancia será de 5
metros a 10 metros es decir son 5 metros
de cambio entonces esto serán 5 metros
sobre segundo
por lo tanto esto nos hace ver de una
manera clara que la tasa de cambio
promedio cambio de de 0 a taiwán a 1 que
entre igualados a t igual a 3 nuestra
tasa de cambio promedio es mayor en este
segundo intervalo que en el primero una
de las cosas más interesantes en las que
puedes pensar es qué pasará si tomas la
pendiente de la recta secante para dos
puntos cada vez más juntos
bueno pues estaremos acercándonos cada
vez más a la pendiente de la recta
tangente y eso es justo lo que haremos
cuando apliquemos el cálculo por ahora
te dejo nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo